greets everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel where this entire week I'm
going to be playing Assassin's Creed
origins at a review event and I thought
that I would bring you guys with me kind
of just to show you what one of these
events is like now first things first we
try really hard not to go to these
events we tried really hard to ask
Ubisoft to give us a copy so that we
don't have to go because the idea of a
review event is a little bit weird
because the publisher controls the
environment that you're in and that's
not what people at home would have so
ultimately we didn't have a choice
but absolutely zero part of me ever
thinks that going to a review event
would influence my school if anything it
makes me slightly annoyed at them going
in but I'm in a weird circumstance this
week because I bunt myself really bad so
I kind of can't sit properly so it's
gonna be I assume a room full of people
on chairs and I'm gonna have to ask if
they can get me something that I can
like sort of lay on so that's not
something that I'm looking forward to
asking for especially if like most of
these events I am the only female
journalist in the room
gonna be extra weird I'm just gonna be
the only chick in the room laying down
and a dress because I but my leg but
we'll get through it alright
I'm pretty much ready to go so let's do
it so the event is at a location in San
Francisco's Mission District after going
to get some stuff for my dumb bone I got
in signing embargo that prevented me
from sharing this video before today and
had the lovely books set me up on a
couch suck it everyone else who's on
plastic seats except this one guy who I
guess had the same idea is me so it
turns out while recording everything in
4k which does mean a bit of juggling
because the hard drives that we have in
a capture kits can only hold so much 4k
footage so that kind of just means I
have to be thinking about what I want to
capture if I've captured enough of
something and then I need to keep track
of what I need to swap the hard drive
out transfer the files delete some of
them and swap a new hard drive in 4k and
4k capture is great but it does add you
know a little bit of shuffling stuff
around but today is mostly about playing
the game coming to grips with what it
actually is and then kind of thinking
about what I'm gonna write in the script
so I know what things I really need to
have game play off it is a long process
but today is probably
the most exciting all right the event
ended at like 7:00 but I'm now at the
IGN offices because I have to edit let's
play such as life so I'll be doing that
hopefully I make it home at 11:00 or so
but for my thoughts of Assassin's Creed
so far I played all day and I got to a
point where I had just met Cleopatra
I'd line a bunch about by ex backstory
and basically all of these really
interesting characters are being
introduced so at this point I'm invested
good morning everyone it is day 2 and
today is the day where I have to really
focus on kind of putting my notes
together I know what the game is I've
put what 10 hours in so far so today's
today that I really need to figure out
what I like and dislike about it one
thing that has stood out to me today I
found a bunch of bugs none of them are
really game breaking honestly mostly
just kind of funny and there will be a
day one patch and I'm playing on xbox
one X meaning this isn't final hardware
so there's like a series of excuses
there but of course a thing that needs
to be seriously considered good morning
friends I just woke up it is day 3 and
I'm gonna be honest I'm getting pretty
stressed at this point I was supposed to
go into work today to phone bunch of
stuff but ultimately said that I can't
because origins is a really big game
it's mostly big because you have to
grind to be able to do one of the main
story missions so there's a lot of side
quest stuff that you have to do and
actually really like all of the side
quests I think they're all like
multifaceted and interesting it's just
that there are some pots where like your
level and the next main quest are like
four levels apart and it takes over an
hour per level so it's taken a while so
yeah hopefully someone at the event
finishes it today because if they do
then I'm I'm pretty much going to also
so wish me luck with that
just finish day three I'm very tired and
also just generally very stressed I
still haven't finished the game
and review events really suck in this
kind of circumstance because you're like
rushing through the game to try and
finish it under this weird pressure that
most people who read your review won't
have like I don't imagine most people
are gonna have to finish this game in
full slash five days so when I start
writing the review like I've written a
bunch of notes and I've kind of started
drafting but I'm gonna have to be really
considerate of that I'm just gonna have
to make sure that I separate myself from
this weird pressure that I'm in to
finish this game which is very long and
that can be a little bit difficult but
thankfully the review and Bob of being
on Thursday means that I do have some
time to like distance myself from the
current stress so that I can think more
about the game itself and honestly you
guys I think it's really good I really
like it I'm also on the home stretch I
think I have to gain three more levels
until I'm done
so yeah it's getting exciting you guys
it's about mid day on day four I finally
finished the game I was very stressed
and then I finally got that so it's done
which means I spend the rest of the time
like exploring other things that I had
and and kind of making my mind up on
some things I'm not sure about and
working on my notes and the one thing
that really I'm struggling with is that
there are single-player
microtransactions in this game I'm
trying to figure out whether I would
have purchased anything with those
microtransactions if I won at this event
I didn't actually spend money but I
wanted to I wanted to buy crafting
supplies specifically and I guess my
thought there is just like what I have
wanted to do this if I want trying to
get through this game or is it that
those supplies are too hard to come by
in the game or I just I have to separate
myself and I'm not even gonna think
about it if I can avoid it until the end
of tomorrow so that I don't screw myself
up pretty much but yeah that's pretty
much gonna be it for this video I will
link you guys to the full review I don't
also link you to a video I made of
exactly the steps I take to write a
review itself but yeah for the next few
days I'm just gonna be
thinking about what to write starting to
write drafts they usually go through
like three or four iterations of drafts
and I think because this game's gonna be
so big I'm gonna have to write like
somewhat close to three thousand words
like it's gonna be a huge review but I
like the game a lot alright I hope you
guys have found this interesting and
kind of an insight into something that
not all old people get to experience
that honestly is pretty rough thank you
guys for watching huge thanks to
everyone who's supporting me on patreon
I'm Alana and I'll see you guys next
time